I am from Assam, which is in the northeastern part of India, and I moved to Delhi almost about 9 years ago for my studies. So when I had gone there for my studies, I was staying in the hostel of the institute that I was associated in, I was studying in.
Once, um, after my hostel tenure was over, I, it was a conscious choice actually to move out of the hostel and I shifted to a PG. Um, so during the time that I was a student, um, I was living in hostels and PG, so it was fine.
Uh, not much of a problem, but when I started working, it was after COVID, after the COVID lockdown restrictions were lifted in 2021, end of 2021. Uh.
Actually early 2022, I started looking for places because I wanted independence and I wanted to live with my friend and I was way too young back then. So I wanted to have, I was the life of party, so I just wanted to enjoy and have no restrictions.
For which I started looking out for flats, and the only issue that I would say that I faced was, um,
Uh, by and large, there was no issue that I faced because of the region that I belong to, but the
The only issue that comes to my mind that I faced was my age and my gender. In the sense, I was young and I was a woman and I was living with another woman and obviously both of us were young and the owner of the house was land, she was a lady. So landlady was a bit of
The interfering kind, she would want to monitor us and she was giving out her place for rent for the first time. So she, it almost made me feel like I was being surveilled and I did not, I was, I was being controlled by.
Someone who has no right to control me, you know, who had no right to control me. So she would, in the pretense of collecting,
Um, rent on cash, she would come every month and sometimes she would call, sometimes she would come uninvited and it was just not a pleasant experience because it felt like I would, I had to make myself available and I was at her beck and call. I had to be at her beck and call otherwise she would.
you know.
to lash out at me and that was very unpleasant. This was after I graduated and I was working. I had actually, yeah, it was during my masters, even though I did masters from a different city, Bombay, but for my field work and because it was just to it was during towards the end of
Hmm.
Uh, the COVID waves, uh, our university wasn't open completely for online classes. So I was still doing it from Delhi because it was a more familiar, uh, town, a familiar city, familiar place. So I just felt more comfortable with that. So I chose to be in Delhi. It was, uh, I had 4 months of my master's left.
So that's when I shifted there and after that while I was at that house only I got my job and I continued to stay there for a couple of months until my land really was upset with me for not.
picking up her call because I was in a meeting or I was out or I was just simply unavailable to pick up her call at random you know, hours of the day. So she was upset and she asked us to leave, but that's my first experience of living independently.
in Delhi, and after that, I moved on to ever since then I have shifted two places. again in the second place. The only concern that I faced was that this was this time around it is regarding my
Uh, of course the age and gender was a factor, but uh, they thought that because I'm a psychologist, I was manipulating the, you know, all those uh, superstition and just um, you know, just the lack of awareness around psychology, psychology and psychologists in India that they thought that I was gonna.
It's they thought that I was, I was.
going to lasso them into something. So they were just very wary of it, uh, that I had to ask my friend to speak for me. She was also living with me, but because she was not a psychologist, they were more comfortable speaking to her. But even then they thought like, uh, the land owner was actually a very aged person and he
He was very nice and cooperative, but because the nephew of the landowner thought that, you know, because I'm a psychologist, I may even go on to manipulate him, he was the one who was dealing.
the negotiations and contract signing and agreement signing at the initial time during the initial phase but he had no other involvement otherwise. So that was my second experience and the third experience that I'm having right now is again the landlord is fine he doesn't even live in Delhi he lives abroad. he
He he's okay by himself. He's a little detached and distant, so he's not always available to solve our concerns, but again, he thinks that, you know, probably we'll be unaware of a lot of things of our rights as tenants, so he can just get away with whatever he does. He's not.
I would want to make this point clear that he's not malicious in any way.
Uh, he or he has no ill intentions, but he just, this is the, this is what I feel that he or me and my friend both of us think that it probably is that he thinks that it's going to be easy for him, uh, to just tell us anything and we'll take it and you know, we will not debate or whatever.
But that's not true. We have had to fight for our rights a lot of times. For instance, if there was a construction problem with the house or if there was a repair that had to be undertaken, a major repair, for instance, water motor repair that needed to be undertaken, it is not the tenant's responsibility.
Uh, because it's not with 1 month or 1 year of usage that the motor gets destroyed. Uh, we knew about it. I had even spoken to my lawyer friends and they assured me of it. Um, we had to fight for it. There was termite treatment that had to be done. Um.
He was initially pressing for the prices, for the charges to be covered by us. But then we really had to, really had to put our foot down, really had to fight and spend so much of our time.
Bye
in fighting for a right that, you know, this is not how it works and we are not going to give it. We are not going to give it so easily. So that's a problem. Now another problem that I would just quickly like to touch upon is, that
Uh, that's our landlord, right? But the whole, so the setup that I stay in is a building and each floor belongs to different people. So, uh, the my flat owner.
also owns the ground floor, and the third floor where I live in. So this there is one of the floors that is in one of the floors there used to be a tenant family before, but right now the owner has come.
And they are very old. The locality that I live in, it's like all the old people live there, hardly ever if any young people, young fashionaries or young women who live by themselves there.
We are one of the rare people who are living by ourselves and he thinks that again it's it's an experience that's quite unpleasant and leaves often leaves a taste in our mouth because
We feel surveilled by him. So if the gate is not closed and even if it is not either me or my friend who has come in, whether it's late in the night or early in the evening, they just try to, you know,
Uh, for lack of a better way to put it, they just try to boss over us and say like, oh, you're responsible for this. Uh, after, after you know, we came in. That is, it's not true that you're not sitting and surveilling all day long, right? It may, may be true that I came in at 9:50 p.m.
And somebody came in after me, I shut the door by myself, after myself. So somebody else came in after me. It just feels like an accusation and after a point you just can't, you're always at loggerheads, you know, and after a point you just give up or just be the bigger person and just accept that you were.
Wrong and just make peace with it. So this has been my experience so far.
I would say I have been able to live on my own terms pretty well, pretty successfully. There haven't been too many sacrifices that I've had to make, but there have been instances where I've had to walk on eggshells, especially when I was younger. You know.
If I had to invite a couple of my friends, whether it was late in the night or in the middle of the day, the neighbors would frown upon us, and we would always be as a younger, as a young woman, like back then 3 years ago when I was younger, I used to be bothered about, oh my god.
What are they gonna say? Are they gonna snitch? Are they gonna, what are they gonna say? Is it going to turn out terribly, well for, terribly, horribly for us? What is, what is gonna happen? What kind of consequences are we gonna have? But eventually we would just let it be because we also want to live our life and...
Yeah, just it would bother us, but it didn't stop us from living.
of living the life, that it didn't bother me from living the life that I wanted.
Initially they used, yeah, there was a lingering sense of anxiety, but I didn't let it overpower me.
Mm-hmm.
Honestly, with the neighbors, this is the only experience that I've had, like I would feel cautious around them, or like I would sometimes tell my friends to.
Just say, you know, like I used to friend them beforehand, saying that if they asked who you were, I would say that you're my cousin, or I would say that you're my family and not my friend. So then at least then that they wouldn't question me.
Just because they used to make it look like that. I really don't know if they would have actually done it, but you just can tell from the vibes of it, right? Like they are probably not going to take it well.
Uh, other than that, it's just that, uh, the current neighbors that I have, they think that because they are much older to us, probably I'm, I'm assuming they're in their late 60s or early even early, possibly even early 70s. Uh, and of course, I'm in my 20s.
So, perhaps they think that, you know, they can, they can.
For lack of a better way to put it again, manipulate us into thinking or just giving in, basically giving in to their demands, you know, they wouldn't want us to. They use the pretense of safety and I understand to an extent that you would want to make sure that you are safe in the place that you are building that you are building.
But, um,
Uh, I don't know what makes them think or question that I as a single woman wouldn't be more worried, uh, of staying alone by myself. Uh.
Like, how can they question that, but they end up doing that. That's kind of a difficult to navigate sometimes. It's frustrating internally, and at the same time you have to be aware of, you have to make sure that you're not rude to them because they're elderly.
Uh, and they don't even want to listen, so there's no point fighting them at all times because fighting them is like banging your head against a wall because they don't want to listen, they just want to have their own way. So that's a bit of a difficulty that I face even now. I have changed as a person, I don't care anymore.
I am aware of my rights. I am aware, my conscience is always clear. And I know that I'm not consciously putting everyone in jeopardy, you know. I am not jeopardizing the safety of anyone. I am taking all the steps that I can to be careful to ensure the safety if that's what the concern is.
So I, my conscience is clean. So I try not to be bothered by them anymore. They try to do whatever they want to do, they will continue to be that way perhaps. But I think I would say the change is internal and more personal.
Having a sense of community always is a powerful currency that one could have. It's also sort of an immunity and knowing your rights, I think is very important. Becoming being more aware of
Uh, your rights as a tenant and, you know, uh, what you can ask for, what you can do, how much of the, how much of a demand you can make and how much you can push.
It definitely makes a difference.